welcome to a new episode of worth it one
stop it's a new show where we try foods
that are uniquely worth it in their own
worth it ways hey this is riya hi today
we're gonna be trying out some expensive
grapes how expensive we were gonna buy
one thousand dollar grapes but we found
out somebody actually bought them in the
last 24 hours so we can't get them
anymore that's crazy yeah so it's worth
it to somebody what would you say are
the main differences between american
grapes and japanese grapes we don't eat
the skin what we peel the skin and eat
the fruit inside interesting you know
what else is in peak season right now
what's up cicadas
oh my gosh you're walking through a
garden and they're just like
dad
wow
yeah it's their garden okay nature's
beautiful i'm not gonna be a hater going
in
you don't have grape expectations
oh nice
that's actually a good one
is that an apple yeah
oh look at the spots this is my favorite
thing this melon the way that the stem
is perfectly straight like that riya do
you have like a favorite fruit peach
it's like bigger juicier those look like
butts and now here are the grapes
they're just like really big don't touch
boy i can't touch this no
no touching it
[Music]
can you tell us a little bit about the
culture of fruits in japan
monica
why are these grapes so expensive this
is not normal right uh
what makes it so expensive
foreign
yeah boom that is a present it looks
like an award too it actually makes a
lot of sense getting a gift of fruit for
somebody if i'm gonna buy you know my
girlfriend a gift and i get her flowers
they're beautiful but she can't eat them
so you're never going to buy your
girlfriend flowers again
if you know yeah no that's not true
sorry no 1 000 grams this is a very nice
box can i keep this box oh yeah the key
component of giving a good gift is the
package that comes in here like a joke
you can't just deliver the punchline
right gotta get the setup you can't just
throw a grape at someone you gotta bring
it in a nice box throw the box at them
it's a nice wood smell to the box good
feel made it unboxing commence
you have a little it's like buying an
iphone with the manual it's like a
certificate and here's how you turn it
on how do you say grape
oh my god they're so heavy i like this
bag it's a breathable bag on the bottom
they're very firm too kind of a baby
heavy it's not the size of a baby small
baby oh yeah oh my god look at how
perfectly lined up those grapes are
these are the grapes in video games you
jump up and eat and they give you a new
life let's eat whoa nature it's
beautiful hold on i gotta i gotta get a
picture of this but
it's me and my grapes can you peel this
oh look at it just take off yeah one two
three four 32 33 34. 35 great so each
grape is 57
the inside is so
special looking oh it's dripping with
juice adam
cheers cheers here's three two one
holy crap like without a doubt okay it
is the best grip i've ever had can i
have another 57 grape it's crazy it kind
of tastes like plum flavor that was
crazy this one looks especially plum
oh yeah 57 more dollars it's a little
disorienting inside putting a grape this
big in your mouth
yeah i've never had a grapes with two
bites right but it's like three or four
bites the firmness is so pleasing too
just like the structural integrity of
the whole bunch it's like i'm lucid
dreaming eating fruit this was really
cool it is very expensive if i gave this
to my girlfriend she would probably cry
from joy
[Music]
the 50 bite right there
that was the juiciest one
the ones at the bottom were the juiciest
how is it
[Music]
oh yes